what is your vision for the game of
chess going forwards I do get the chance
in February to do something that I've
never done before and that in chess
either which is to play Fish random
Chess at a classical time control I'm
really looking forward to do that cuz
fish random chess I think it's always
been played in Rapid time control which
never made a lot of sense to me since
you have to think for move one then you
need more time to think and for
classical chess there's a lot of theory
so you would need less time so it's
better to play rapid and Blitz there um
instead and that's one of the visions
that I have for the future that there
will be more fish random chest or other
variants for classical and that regular
chess will be more rapid and Blitz which
I think it's better better suited for
classical time control for fish random
and other than that you envision faster
chess basically faster chess is the is
the future